2024 is going to be the biggest year
ever for elections most people in the
world will be living in a country that
has national elections so on the face of
it this is a great Triumph for democracy
but there's a difference between
quantity and quality there's going to be
a presidential election in Russia for
example and I think we can all guess
already who's going to win but there are
other elections that are worth watching
where they're genuinely competitive and
it's going to be a big deal who wins one
of the early ones in the year is the
election in Taiwan there will be a
choice between a more China friendly
candidate and a more sort of independent
leading candidate and that will
influence relations across the Taiwan
straight but also us China tensions then
there's the Indian election in the
middle of the year which is the biggest
election in the world but of course the
election everyone's going to be watching
most closely is the election in the
United States at the end of the year and
the question of whether Donald Trump
comes back for another term would he
pull out of NATO would he pull out of
climate treaties would he pull the plug
on aid for
Ukraine nobody knows and that's why
everybody would be watching that
election particularly closely